- It's always worth it to do your best,
and to believe in something,
and to work towards the
attainment of the goal.
There's a saying that says,
"You could lead a horse to the water,"
- [Interviewer] But you can't...
- "But you can't make them drink."
Plan, you plan.
"But what about if this comes up?"
You don't get caught off guard.
Proper preparation
prevents poor performance.
You know, if you work hard,
and your work is recognized,
you know, the sky's the limit.
- He's an American
professional body builder,
personal trainer, artist and actor.
His most recent victory was
the 2016 Arnold Classic.
He also came second
place in the 2012, 2013,
and 2014 Mr. Olympia.
He's Kai Greene,
and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success.
Rule #2 is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also, once Kai is talking,
if he says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(uplifting music)
- 2015 Mr. Olympia is
fastly approaching and
I am regrettably
of the realization that I am
not going to be allowed to compete.
Let me just say that I have,
I have invested more
than 20 years of my life
in the belief in the idea
of being able to come to the Olympia,
and to do an absolute best,
despite whatever the opposition,
whatever's said,
whatever the beliefs are,
onstage, offstage,
whatever the oppositionary
forces have been,
my resolve has been to
respond as a champion,
and just aim to
represent the better thought
of what that means to me.
You don't get this far,
you don't get to this point,
and just stop.
(sniffs) It doesn't happen like that.
I am...
I'm not a victim, I'm not a...
They ain't going to break me,
and I don't want to speak
negatively at anybody.
I don't want to speak negatively
about anything, you know.
Let me just say that
there's more going on than,
than I'm able to say.
(sobs)
It's not fair.
I can't say that.
What they're doing,
what's being done,
why it's actually happening,
it is what it is.
You know, we talk about
overcoming objections,
and a lot of times we don't know exactly
what those objections will be,
and sometimes they can come up,
and they can be so overwhelming that,
wow, we didn't anticipate
that, we didn't know,
but we just...
We got to still aim to do,
and still believe and recognize
that there are things that are...
It's always worth it to do your best,
and to believe in something,
and to work towards the
attainment of the goal,
and if it is
that you have to expand your vision,
then you climb higher and you do that,
and you don't be afraid to.
2015 Olympia weekend is going to come
(sniffs)
I am a champion,
as are you,
not because
of the trophies and titles,
but because of the
obstacles that you overcome,
and the effort that you exert
to find what it is to be your best,
and to aim to do it
because you decide to,
and recognize that it
is your right (sniffs),
and your responsibility to do so.
There's a lot of work
that we're responsible for
that other people can't do,
you know.
There's a saying that says,
"You can lead a horse to the water,"
- [Interviewer] But you can't...
- "But you can't make them drink."
In the presence of common
sense and rational thinking,
when even in the throes of your despair,
it is your responsibility,
if you are willing to still commit
to saving your own life,
to hear that,
and just walk towards
that voice, you know.
So, you know,
I want to recognize personal
responsibility, you know,
and in what we try to do here today,
one of things that make, you know,
body building a significant vehicle
for therapy, and maybe even a tool,
you know, towards personal development
is just that.
You know, in order to be
able to do this effectively,
you have to recognize your
personal responsibility.
So, with that said,
you know,
I am going to submit to
you that the word believe,
believe is work.
You can substitute work for believe,
you know, because when I'm working,
what are you working for?
If you're working without a belief
in the idea that you going to get paid,
then what is your work for?
What is the purpose?
So, I believe that, you know,
to talk about believing is to talk
about being willing to do the work.
First, let me say that I think
the goals pretty much set
the tone for everything else.
So,
you know,
I guess when you think about goal setting,
and when you really
allow your goals to start
becoming the lead
to manage your steps,
then your life path starts to become
guided,
and not just haphazard,
and by chance.
You're goals become the
predetermined address
that will serve as a destination
and end result,
and now,
with at least that,
you're able to make decisions
and map out a course,
step by step if you will,
that will help get you there.
The really cool thing about
goal setting is that
even if you do not have
all the information
beyond the address,
like what streets, when and where to turn,
with having the address,
you can always type in GPS coordinate,
and pretty much take advantage of
other sensibilities
that can help point you
in the right direction.
A lot of times, you
don't really need to have
all of the guess work predetermined
and already figured out,
once you have the address,
you're that much closer
to being able to get
where you're trying to go.
As an athlete on stage,
that's kind of what I'm using to
help get me
where I feel I need to be
to perform at the maximum efficiency.
So, yeah, goal setting is
very, very, very important,
and it's been very, very
critical in helping me get
from the beginning of my career
to where I am presently.
Still don't feel like you've quite arrived
at the right answer, right?
You know, is this...
"Okay, should I do three
of these, or is it six?
"Or is it 45 minutes, or is it an hour?
"So I just go ahead and finish, you know,
"get the two-hour session in.
"Hey, I feel this way.
"Do I need to stop?
"No, you know what, I
know I feel this way,
"but I need to continue.
"Is it healthier for me to stop?
"Oh no, no, I'm good, I'm good, I got it.
"Let me continue, let me push it.
"I know I said I was only going to have
"this many grams of carbs today,
"but is that light-headedness,
"or is it that I just
really want more carbs?"
It's troubleshooting all day.
"Should I take an extra
two grams of protein?
"Will it really matter?
"How much sodium?
"Dammit, you know, you
can't eat out anymore.
"I have two meals with
me and then, you know,
"the rest, you know, I can eat out
for these next two meals."
No, you cook every meal.
You prepare for all day.
Your steps do not happen
randomly by chance.
Plan, you plan.
"But what about if this comes up?"
You don't get caught off guard.
Proper preparation
prevents poor performance.
It's your responsibility
to plan, to prepare.
This is your dream.
The achieving great
things though comes from,
you know,
the ability to manage yourself
very, very, very well,
you know, or at least well enough
where you almost become compulsive
about getting certain things done,
you know.
You have to set a standard for yourself
that is very, very, very high,
you know,
and you have to manage yourself
to keep your thoughts
where they need to be
in order to allow you
to be successful at what
you're trying to do.
One way you can say "Absolutely, I can,"
is not with your mouth,
but with your actions,
and actions are the product of thought,
so if you're continuing to think
like I was saying when we were training,
"Am I doing this as good as I can?
"Can I command more from myself?
"Am I connecting with this muscle
"as intensely as I can connect?
"Am I training hard enough?"
You know, "Can I train harder?"
Obstacles really don't matter.
They really just don't,
no more than where you come from,
what you had, what you
have, what you didn't have.
All that stuff becomes so what?
People that are
concerned with
results,
and the person that's working
with their mind fixed on
the end result being success
are a lot less
concerned about the problems,
and they're more willing
to explore solutions,
and if need be, create them.
That is, probably, the
best use of your energy.
Arnold Schwarzenegger was
said to once give a seminar
somewhere.
I think they reference it in either the,
the book The Education of a Bodybuilder,
or Arnold Schwarzenegger's
Encyclopedia of Bodybuilding.
One time giving a
seminar, it was said that,
he talked about
focusing on his goal,
and how the only time you can begin
to really assess the
enormity of an obstacle,
was to have to first take
your eye off your goal.
That's the end of my Arnold
Schwarzenegger quote,
but I guess in recalling
that at this moment,
what I realize is, you know,
if I'm an NFL
outside linebacker looking to try
to put a sack on the quarterback
of the opposing team,
if I am looking at the size
of the lineman in front of me
looking to stop me, the
defenders looking to stop me
from getting to the quarterback,
if I start taking into account,
"Wow, how big is his hands," and
"How much does this guy weigh," and
"Man, look at the size of his neck,"
chances are,
in order to make all of those assessments,
I can't be looking at the
quarterback behind him anymore,
and if my responsibility in this play
was to put pressure on the quarterback,
and even better,
put my hands on the quarterback,
cause a fumble to stop the play,
then I'm going to be rendered ineffective,
not by anything the lineman has done,
but because I have now
taken my eye off of the goal
in order to assess
the size and weight of the
obstacle in front of me.
Successful people,
I imagine, have to worry less about
what the size of the obstacles are,
the finances or the lack thereof,
and all the other things that we can say
represent the size and
weight of the opposition.
What the successful person
is going to aim to do,
and what all of us that
would like to be successful
would, probably, want to adopt
as a part of our philosophy would be
to worry less about the obstacles,
and fix our thoughts on
the goal.
It's one thing to philosophize
about training strategies and to,
you know,
compare this philosophy versus another,
argue about, you know, how many grams
versus how many grams is...
But then there's something to be said
about doing the damn thing.
You know,
just do it.
You know, stop talking,
stop trying to sound smart.
You meet these people
that want to engage you
in these conversations,
and one-up the professional body builder.
"Ah, I know more about nutrition,"
well then, dude, I mean...
I'm not...
Straight.
I'm not where I'm at because
I know more about nutrition
than everybody else on the planet.
You know, in fact, I daresay that
the top body building
athletes that are onstage
are not the man onstage...
You make a right here.
Because they know more about
training science and nutrition
than the average person
sitting in the audience.
A lot of time, the
difference between the person
in the audience and the person
that's onstage doing it,
is the use of the knowledge.
Success is not based on genetics.
It's not based on how nice this car is.
It's not based on how pretty my face is,
how small my nose may need to look,
or, you know,
whether or not I'm the right complexion.
I have an eight inch scar
down the side of my face,
but I have a camera in front of me
more often than not,
which just means that, you know,
if you work hard,
and your work is recognized,
you know, the sky's the limit.
For all those people out there
that think they're ugly and everything,
Ima hold it down for you, but
more importantly, you know,
you can still be a success.
For all those people that think,
"Well, I'm too short,"
well, I'm holding down for you.
More importantly, you
can still be a success.
Find the things that you're excited about,
and that you can give your all,
and you can work really
hard towards attaining.
String those days of efficiency,
efficient action together,
and success can happen even for you.
This is my life,
but this is also me living it.
You tune in,
and what you should walk away from,
what I would want you
most to walk away with,
is the idea of, "Yo,
"but what can I do?
"What am I doing with my life?
"Am I living it or am I just,
"you know, going to some hum-drum job
"that I don't really want to be at
"doing some minuscule task,
"getting paid to be a mindless drone,"
you know,
"Or am I out there living life
"on my terms
"they way I want to live it,
"doing the things that I want to do?"
Make no mistake about it.
As hard as this is,
as hard as this is,
this is what I want to do.
This is what I want to do, you know,
and some people can make fun of it.
They can crack jokes.
They can sit back and analyze,
and, you know,
criticize,
and make all the fun they want,
but I'm living my life.
I'm doing it.
What are you?
The mind is everything.
If you don't believe you can do something,
then you can't.
If you believe that your father was a bum,
and he left you,
or your mother wasn't any good,
if you believe that your
upbringing was substandard,
and therefore, you have to walk around
as a refugee from that crazy situation
for the rest of your life,
forever bearing
the burden of that experience,
then that will be your life.
It's like you have to save your own life.
Nobody's going to be
able to save it for you,
so we have to do what we have to do,
no matter what it is.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Abdullah Aqili asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Kai say
that had the biggest impact on you?
What was the biggest take away lesson
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or to your business?
Leave it in the comments,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Kris Schantz from happyworker.com.
Kris, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and posting the picture on Twitter.
I love the picture,
and it really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- Those star moments,
that, you know, fill the highlight reels,
and, you know, leave an
audience in awe to watch.
"Oh, wow, play that again.
"I want to see that."
Those seconds are built
on thousands and thousands
and thousands of hours
that a lot of people
wouldn't think are worth,
you know, adding to a highlight reel.
Basic fundamentals being applied
over and over and over and over again.
Getting up a certain time,
doing certain things,
cooking your meals, going to,
you know, do your cardio,
walking through the disciplines,
keeping the checklists,
and staying on top of them,
those are the things that,
you know, when you string them together,
start to create a day of efficient action.
The more likely you are
to string those days
of efficient action together,
the more likely it will be
that you can set up your own success.
(whispering with somber music)
I refuse to believe
today will be just another day in my life.
All that I am,
all that I will become,
will be written through my thoughts,
and my actions.
- This is our show, all right?
Our show.
♫ Take me to church
♫ I worship like a dog at
the shrine of your lies
♫ I'll tell you my sins and
you can sharpen your knife
♫ Offer me that deathless death
♫ Good God, let me give you my life
- [Kai] I've conditioned my mind,
trained my body,
sacrificed my soul.
- We know we're better than this.
Let's (expletive bleeped) show it now.
Let's go.
- There will be obstacles,
doubters,
mistakes,
but nothing comes to those who wait.
Every champion was once a contender
that refused to give up.
♫ Take me to church, I worship--
(typing)
(somber music)
♫ Like you
♫ Be strong
♫ To hold the powers of the sun
♫ To dream
♫ Believe
♫ In strength, now I'm the only one
♫ Only one
♫ I was an ordinary boy
♫ Until I broke the
rules my life destroyed
♫ My life destroyed
♫ Until I woke awake
♫ To scream my mind
♫ I shout, the ground shakes
♫ How much can I take
♫ My mind will break
♫ Will it break
♫ Can I take
♫ Can I be your superhero
♫ Superhero
(electronic rock music)
♫ Can I be your superhero
♫ Superhero
♫ Fly up
♫ Away
♫ It's the first time of today
♫ Today
♫ To dream
♫ Believe
♫ You are the strength
♫ You're all I need
♫ Need
♫ Oh, going to give it a shot
♫ Only one of me
♫ To shoot you all from the enemy
♫ Your superhero
(electronic rock music)
♫ Can I be your superhero
♫ Superhero